JENNY MURPHY: Hi everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
This week we're going to be
talking about the new release
of the Hangouts APIs,
version--
which number?
WILL THOMPSON and
JOHN BERRY: 1.1.
JENNY MURPHY: 1.1 It adds a lot
of cool new functionality.
And we have some engineers
from the team joining us.
And a bunch of people from the
community, so we should have a
nice, fun discussion.
So before we dive into stuff,
let's tell you a little bit
about ourselves.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google.
I focus mostly on
the [? reft ?]
APIs and the social plug-ins,
like the +1 Button.
But I like hacking Hangout apps
when I have the time.
And I'm joined here today by--
MARTIN: Hi, I'm Martin.
I'm a software engineering
intern at Google.
And I'm working on a Google+
3 [? project. ?]
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
And, if you remember, he's
actually been on the other end
of these Hangouts
pretty often.
So it's great to have
you in person.
JOHN BERRY: And hi, yes
everybody, I'm John Berry.
I'm the develop advocate for
Google+ working on Hangouts.
WILL THOMPSON: I'm
Will Thompson.
I'm a developer programs
engineer on Hangouts.
JENNY MURPHY: And then joining
us over the Hangout from left
to right, from my view,
we have Alan.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: Hi there,
I'm Alan Furtzenburg.
I'm an outside developer.
I mostly develop Hangout apps.
I'm most known for my caption
app, and the app appearing in
my upper left hand corner is
the My Time Hangout app.
JENNY MURPHY: Now say
hi to Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah hi, I'm
Gerwin from Austria.
I do lots of stuff with the
Google APIs for fun, actually.
So probably my most well-known
Hangout app is the Comment
Tracker, but I'm doing lots of
different stuff with WebGL.
And I just tried the face
tracking thing, and just
playing around really.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool, we're
actually using the Comment
Tracker today, so.
JD?
JD SALAZAR: Hey, I'm JD Salazar,
and I'm a developer
on the Hangouts API team.
JENNY MURPHY: Next, Moritz.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Hi, I'm Moritz
from Germany, and I'm
also playing around with
the Hangouts API a lot.
And I think I'm most common for
my two apps, I deal a lot
with the Hangout Lower
Third and the Hangout
Volume Control apps.
JENNY MURPHY: And, last but
not least, Richard.
RICHARD DUNN: And I'm
Richard Dunn.
I'm the lead for the
Hangouts API team.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
According to your lower third,
you're apparently Google.
RICHARD DUNN: You're
all of Google.
JENNY MURPHY: You're
JD SALAZAR: All in one, one for
all, that's what I say.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So we were talking about
the latest release of
the Hangouts API.
Richard, would you like to give
us a little overview of
what's been added
in this release?
RICHARD DUNN: Sure, yeah.
We added a bunch of stuff
this time around.
The first thing we added was
facial motion detection and
getting the data where
the face is.
So in the past we've had images
that can track the
face, and now we're actually
exposing that data so that any
app can use it to display
whatever they like.
Or use it to control a game
or anything like that.
We also released a new way of
broadcasting messages to
instances of your app, which
lets it go much faster.
Use it for things like sending
mouse movements or tracking an
object in a game, things
like that.
We added static overlays.
So images that you can overlay
over your video that don't
track a facial feature but
are fixed on the screen.
And there's obviously
examples of that
running in this Hangout.
The Lower Thirds app, which
is fixing the names there.
And I believe Alan's Time is
probably using that as well.
And then we added a bunch
of miscellaneous stuff.
You know, ways to figure out
whether the Hangout is an on
air Hangout, whether it's
a public Hangout.
And we did some changes actually
based on developer
feedback, which was allowing you
to see the names of people
that aren't using the app.
I believe Moritz needed that
for volume control, because
you'd like to be able
to identify whose
volume you're affecting.
I think that's about it.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: This also has
the first of the on-air
features, correct?
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah.
So we just started with whether
the hangout is an on
air Hangout, and whether
it's broadcasting.
And we obviously plan to
add a bunch of stuff
in that area soon.
JOHN BERRY: And there's both
the methods and as well as
events for that?
RICHARD DUNN: Correct.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
It's a lot of neat stuff.
We're really looking forward to
seeing what people will do
with some of these features.
I'm kind of excited
about the face
tracking, the data stream.
And there's a lot of
cool potential.
I'm waiting for someone to write
a robotic camera that
tracks faces.
I'll do that.
If someone else does
it, I'll send you
a t-shirt or something.
JOHN BERRY: Well, Will's
camera has got
a pretty cool WebGL.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, the giant
floating robot head.
Yeah, it's actually in the video
that we released when we
released the version 1.1.
Yeah, it's just--
we have a roll, pan, and tilt.
And I hook that up to a cube
to kind of move it around.
And then, I made the mouth move
up and down with volume.
Although, actually I want to go
back and change that so it
actually moves with the top and
bottom lip endpoints, or
attach points.
The other thing is, I was able
to go zoom in and out.
And we're able to do zoom in and
out by basically using the
scale between your eye and
the tip of your nose.
That should stay constant
the entire time.
If your nose is like moving
out someplace
it's going to be bad.
That person's going to have
suboptimal performance.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, I actually
use the distance between the
two eyes to measure the zoom.
So that's what I use for that.
WILL THOMPSON: That's how
the Wii works too.
It sees those two points
and zooms in and out.
And that's how you know how
far away the controller is
from the thing.
Yeah, it works really well.
I would worry that if I was
using-- well, it's probably
the same either way--
whether if you turn your head
and zoom in and out, whether
the two eyes close together or
these two close together are
going to be better or worse.
But anyway, it's pretty neat.
I hope to release [INAUDIBLE]
for that really soon.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN BERRY: You also did some
cool things like you added
weighting and
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, I
absolutely used smoothing.
I'll show you the code
as soon as I can.
It's basically weight--
I have a five frame smoothing,
and I weight the most recent
frame the highest but still use
those other five frames.
It does mean that if you shake
your head like this really
fast it doesn't move quite as
much, but that's OK as long as
you're not Richard Nixon
or something.
JENNY MURPHY: I think the
probability of Richard Nixon
using your Hangout app
is pretty low.
WILL THOMPSON: That would
be pretty low.
You know, I should probably
make a Richard
Nixon robot head, too.
That would be
[INTERPOSING VOICES].
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I was thinking
about creating a
head-controlled pong game.
[INAUDIBLE]
by moving your head up and
down or something.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah.
One of the things that I would
absolutely recommend is that
you put a mustache or something
on whoever the face
is tracking right now.
Because one of the things I
discovered during testing is
it would lock on to somebody
standing behind me.
And I would be like, God, it's
not working, what's this?
[LAUGHTER]
WILL THOMPSON: Then I realized,
oh wait it's--
JOHN BERRY: Another cool idea
that I heard was like soccer,
or using your head to bounce a
ball back up and down, and
then knocking it over
to somebody else.
WILL THOMPSON: Head
hacky sack.
JOHN BERRY: Yeah.
JENNY MURPHY: That would
be pretty cool.
Cool.
So I see some questions
are starting to
pile up on the feed.
And this is primarily a question
and answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions,
go find the announcement
post on the Google+
developers plus page.
And it should be pretty
close to the top now,
because it's active.
And it's also linked from the
original post of this
broadcast. And ask your question
there and we will
respond to it live at some
point in this session.
WILL THOMPSON: I have
some questions.
JENNY MURPHY: You do Will?
WILL THOMPSON: I do.
I actually have questions that
Alan asked on the newsgroup
and I haven't had a chance
to respond to it yet.
I figured we could ask
Richard and JD.
Here, I'm going to
read from Alan.
So if we don't set the scale for
our bottom thirds, for our
non-tracking overlays, what
does the system assume?
JD SALAZAR: I believe the
default is width--
the references width
and a scale of one.
WILL THOMPSON: OK.
Also, I know there's a method
to get to display ratio.
Will the ratio change
during the Hangout?
JD SALAZAR: No, it shouldn't.
WILL THOMPSON: OK.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I think
there's a slight small issue
or mistake in the reference.
JD SALAZAR: OK.
Let me just find it.
WILL THOMPSON: Live document
debugging right here.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
We could to change it
at the same time?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MORITZ TOLXDORFF:
I can't find it.
JOHN BERRY: If you can actually
send us that link.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah,
send us the link.
JOHN BERRY: We'll be
happy to update it.
WILL THOMPSON: OK.
And the last question is about
resolution of the feed.
One of the things that's
interesting is how wide is the
feed exactly, so that I can make
ideally-sized overlays.
And I guess it would be
interesting for you guys to
address some of that.
JD SALAZAR: Sure.
So the problem with that is
it's camera-dependent.
So even more than that, it's
camera-dependent and what we
detect with reference
to your computer.
Like how much load there
is and so forth.
And so you can't really
guarantee anything about the
resolution.
I think we could look into
giving some guidelines on
approximate image sizes that
we think might look good.
But I don't think we'll ever
be able to tell you exactly
what the resolution is so that
you can optimize perfectly.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: And I think
we can understand and
appreciate that.
I think guidelines would
really, really help.
Or at the very least, an API
method that told us what the
maximum resolution is, or
something along those lines.
Because I know when I started
playing with the static
graphics, I pretty quickly
figured out what the numbers
were going to be that I
usually ended up with.
And that gave me an idea
for what maximum I
should design for.
But even scaling down from that
doesn't always look good,
and certainly if I needed to
scale up to that, it'll come
out really badly.
JD SALAZAR: Right.
Yeah, I think that there's
definitely work we can do in
both providing guidelines
outside of the API to what
looks good, and also trying to
come up with ways in the API
to give you feedback on what
might look good in specific
situations.
That's definitely a to-do
item for us, I think.
JOHN BERRY: And you know, we
say this all the time, but
since you've experimented, I'm
sure other developers would
love to hear about those ranges,
and how you found
those useful.
And we'd love to hear feedback
in terms of what we could be
recommending, too.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
JOHN BERRY: So that was
all the questions?
WILL THOMPSON: Those are
Alan's questions?
JENNY MURPHY: Unless you
thought of any in
the interim, Alan.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: Oh,
I've thought of
plenty in the interim.
And in fact, I know I emailed
some of them last night while
I was in the middle of trying
to get the clock working.
The documentation indicates
that the URLs for an image
resource should be either HTTP,
HTTPS, or a data URL.
I had trouble getting the
HTTPS one working.
And one of the things I realized
is that there's no
error called if it can't
load an image resource
for whatever reason.
A, am I correct about the fact
that HTTPS is not supported?
And B, is there supposed to be
some indication somewhere that
it can't load a resource?
And I guess the follow up to C
is, if either of those are no,
what can be done
to change this?
JD SALAZAR: OK, so an
HTTPS should work.
And if you're experiencing
problems, then--
WILL THOMPSON: Well, one thing
you can do is absolutely send
us a piece of sample code that
demonstrates the error.
And we can take a look
at that, definitely.
I saw your email and was like,
yeah that's interesting.
Let me go try that.
And I haven't had a chance
to try it yet.
J.D. SALAZAR: B, you are
correct that we do not
currently provide any feedback
as to whether the image was
loaded or not, and we're
working on it.
That's definitely high on the
list of things that we want to
add, I think.
JOHN BERRY: Just get better
feedback, or specifically
about the overlays?
WILL THOMPSON: Just when a
overlay fails to load.
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, I think
in general for any image
resources we'll look into adding
some type of event that
tells you when it loaded
and if it loaded.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: In my case--
I just posted the code
in the chat.
I'm basically just doing the
forward slash, and just
leaving out the HTTP or
HTTPS, so the Hangout
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
whatever it should use.
But actually, it should use
HTTPS, because the Hangout is
running HTTPS as well.
And this is working
fine without
any error or something.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: I couldn't
get it to use a
relative URL at all.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I had some
issues when I was running my
apps on my own server, but it
has issues with a non-trusted
certificate and stuff.
But since I run everything
on AppSpot, it's running
perfectly fine.
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, that would be
my I guess for you, Alan,
is that it has something to do
with the certificate that is
being used.
The talk plug-in isn't quite
as accepting as Chrome is.
So you might be able to hit
the URL in Chrome, but the
talk plug-in might have issues
with the certificate.
But we can look at that.
JOHN BERRY: Alan, I'm more
talking about a protocol
relative URL.
WILL THOMPSON: So instead
of just a
relative URL, it's HTTPS.
And instead of saying HTTPS
colon slash slash, whatever,
you just leave off the first
HTTPS colon slash.
And then whatever protocol you
used to get there, it'll use
that one to get the
next resource.
JOHN BERRY: You'll see--
ALAN FURTZENBURG: But in this
case that would have failed.
Because it loads the rest of the
resources securely, but it
can't load the image
resources securely.
WILL THOMPSON: Well,
in your case.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we'll
get to the bottom of it.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah.
Send us some code and a link
to the image that's not
working, and we'd be curious.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
So are there any other questions
in the Hangout?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah.
What about adding animated
GIF support?
JENNY MURPHY: Animated
GIFs as overlays?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah.
Right now you probably can
load PNGs and JPEGs.
JOHN BERRY: And data URLs.
WILL THOMPSON: Well, data
URLs may contain--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah,
and data URLs.
Sure.
An animated GIF would
be quite cool.
I had some ideas with that.
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, I think
that's an option.
I think also just better support
for animating image
resources in general.
Such that you can have some
guarantees about showing and
hiding images will happen in
the same frame, could help
with that too.
It's not the same.
An animated GIF is obviously
an easier way to do it.
But I think both of those
things are something
we should work on.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: And would it
also be possible to add text
or other elements to the UI
without messing up the whole
video pane?
Like, just adding somewhere a
button or text somewhere in
the UI as an addition?
JOHN BERRY: Can you give
us an example?
What kind of thing are
you looking for?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: What was it?
WILL THOMPSON: Where in
the interface do you
want to add this text?
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, can you
give us the specifics?
You know, a story, tell us the
story about how you'd use it?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: For example,
my volume control app, right?
I have the mute Hangout button,
and that if I want to
place the button not inside the
left extension pane, and I
want to move it up where the
microphone and video mute
buttons are.
Something like that.
JOHN BERRY: So you want
to influence the outer
Chrome of the UI.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Right.
JENNY MURPHY: That would
be really cool.
It's a lot of potential
there but--
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I mean, sure
you can mess around a lot
then, but if you do it
right you can produce
some awesome stuff.
WILL THOMPSON: Just put white
boxes over everything.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY MURPHY: You can
no longer exit.
[LAUGHTER]
WILL THOMPSON: Yes,
it's the no exit.
JENNY MURPHY:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
JOHN BERRY: Until the
Hangout cuts out.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah, that
way you can actually create
your own themes for Hangouts.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
JOHN BERRY: All right,
so [UNINTELLIGIBLE]--
ALAN FURTZENBURG: It has been a
feature that a lot of people
who were broadcasting without
using Hangouts on air have
been requesting.
JOHN BERRY: The Hangouts team
in general is every day
looking at how to
improve the UI.
And we've gone through at least
two major UI refreshes
since we launched.
And the developer feature has
to go hand in hand with the
user experience, you know,
the end user feature.
So that's great feedback for
thinking of the future.
There is no plan I know of
today to add that, but
something to look into.
JENNY MURPHY: Yep, cool.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: A broad
question about resources and
image resources.
There's a note in the API guide
that warns us that once
images are allocated in the
plug-in, they can't
deallocated.
How big of a problem is this
really, and is there any work
being done on being able to
free up those resources?
JD SALAZAR: Yes, there
is work being done.
And it's probably not a problem
unless you're loading,
like, hundreds or thousands
of images.
WILL THOMPSON: I was going to
say, I've definitely crashed
the Hangout when I was loading
images like crazy, but that
was when I was loading them
almost every frame.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
JOHN BERRY: I mean, certainly we
can try it with 100 images
on a MacBook Air and it works,
for 100 overlays, and that's
not a problem.
So I can tell you that's
my benchmark.
[LAUGHTER]
ALAN FURTZENBURG: OK.
The reason I ask is, I know
Moritz and I had been talking
about doing digital clocks.
And one of the questions was,
well why don't you just create
a canvas, put the text on it,
and replace the image from the
canvas every minute
or every second?
And I'm like, well, because
you're allocating all these
images and they're never
going to get freed up.
And there was--
MORITZ TOLXDORFF:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] will crash.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: And there
was some people who were
surprised like, come on, you've
got to be freeing up
the image resources somewhere.
And I'm like, the documentation
says they don't
get freed up.
JD SALAZAR: Yeah.
It's definitely important for us
to provide a way for you to
free them up to do
things like that.
But for now I would say, as a
general guideline, if you're
in the low hundreds of images
it's probably, won't have much
of a problem.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, it depends
on how big they are.
JOHN BERRY: And also--
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, that's true.
JOHN BERRY: I noticed, that also
includes other overlays.
So the sound overlays also
take up memory and do
not get freed up.
So if you have a bunch of images
and a bunch of sounds,
you should be [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: By the way,
are the sounds broadcasted to
all the participants,
or only locally?
I think only locally, right?
J.D. SALAZAR: Yeah.
That's correct.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah.
And actually, if you play them
through the plug-in, they are
more likely to be
noise-cancelled.
Which is a great use for if
you want to alert somebody
without alerting everybody,
rather than using an HTML5
audio tag or something, you
can just be like, bong,
through the plug-in.
So if you're making a game
that takes turns or
something like that.
It's a very easy part.
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, that's
probably the best part about
using the audio in the API is
that you should get echo
cancellation most of the time.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Are you
planning on broadcasting
sounds to our participants like
you do with the overlay?
JD SALAZAR: Yeah, that's a
heavily requested feature and
something we're looking
at adding.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Cool.
And also, what I would
like to see--
I mean, with my volume control
when I mute the Hangout, now I
have the overlay to indicate
that I muted the Hangout.
And it would also be cool if I
get notifications on top of
the Hangout, that I'm able to
broadcast these notifications
to all the participants.
Like, when I block someone
it shows up
on everybody's Hangout.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] the
people in the Hangout that I
muted the Hangout for me.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, we only
provide that the same way we
did the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] avatar,
which is that you
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] state, and
then have each of the
individual apps post
it themselves.
WILL THOMPSON: But yeah,
that's cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Agreed.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: And another
more general thing is a lot of
people asking me how they can
remove an app they installed.
Which is currently
not possible.
Because when you try out a lot
of apps, at some point you
just think the app is not worth
having it installed.
And you want to remove it.
There's no way to do it.
You can revoke access, but
this is not enough.
The app is still showing up in
your Recent tab and whatever.
WILL THOMPSON: It can be
incriminating, depending.
If you have poker in
there and you're
working out or something.
JOHN BERRY: Unless you work
for a video game company.
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah, we agree.
We definitely need
a way to do that.
It's in progress.
You can revoke the permissions
for the app.
WILL THOMPSON: Yes.
You can go to
Google.com/dashboard, and
click on the revoke
permissions.
RICHARD DUNN: I mean,
they really have
no permissions out.
If you don't run them in the
Hangout, they really have no
permission to do anything.
I mean, they're not running.
It's not like they're
offline apps.
But yes, that will
be coming soon.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, this is an
artifact of the fact that, on
the Hangouts, we're moving
really fast. So lots of cool
stuff is coming out.
This is just one of those
rough edges where
we'll clean it up.
Hang tight.
RICHARD DUNN: It's a happy
problem to have, that people
have too many apps that
they feel like they
need to remove some.
JENNY MURPHY: Exactly.
JOHN BERRY: I mean, as I develop
a lot, I have probably
40 that are just called
Hangout app.
So I'd love to get
that feature.
RICHARD DUNN: So fill in
your metadata people.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah,
especially you.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, I was going
to say, I may actually
be the person who has the most
apps in their API console.
I think I win.
Yeah, and everybody who calls
them Hangout gadget--
I have this sea of
Hangout gadgets.
JOHN BERRY: Cool, you want to
jump to the comment screen?
JENNY MURPHY: Sure.
So I'm going to be reading
some questions from the
comment stream.
So again, if you're watching
and you'd like to ask a
question go to the Google+
developers page
and you can ask there.
There's an announcement post
where you can post your
questions, and we'll find
them and answer them.
So I'm going to start from the
oldest questions first. And
Joshua Owen asked, yesterday--
way ahead of the curve--
asked the question, is there any
way through the [? dom ?]
to identify the user's filmstrip
partitions on the
bottom filmstrip?
It would be great if we could
drag and drop things from our
Hangout app onto a person's
partition to initiate actions.
RICHARD DUNN: So, two
answers to that.
One, yes, you do have their
filmstrip position.
It's in the participant
object.
So you can use that.
And I don't know if we'll do
anything as complicated as
drag and drop, but we've
definitely identified that
people want a quick way to
do some action that's
based on the user.
So we'll be looking into ways
that maybe we can either
circle, click events on
the film strip or
something like that.
So that people can initiate an
action on a particular user
without having to reimplement
that UI.
Like--
ALAN FURTZENBURG: Well--
no, sorry.
Finish first.
RICHARD DUNN: Like volume
control, right?
I mean, you have that list, but
it might just be easier if
it's, like, click on a person,
and then adjust their volume.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: I think
related to that is also the
question that I get a bit is,
are you guys looking at being
able to position the individual
small thumbnails
elsewhere on the screen, like
we can position the large
video stream anywhere
on screen?
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah, we're
definitely looking at that.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: OK awesome.
JOHN BERRY: And, you know, I've
seen people experiment
with the filmstrip position
for example.
Because if you know how many
persons you have, and you kind
of know how wide
each object is.
And you're using the drag data
from the JavaScript, you know
you've exited the eye frame.
Right?
So you can just assume, kind
of, that they're there.
JENNY MURPHY: So you can put
little air hockey gates at the
bottom of the screen?
RICHARD DUNN: It's definitely
hack, though.
Because any minor tweak to the
UI could screw that up.
JD SALAZAR: There's also a
problem where if you have an
extension open, then you can't
actually get to some people on
the filmstrip.
Right?
It will obscure the people
on the left, for example.
JENNY MURPHY: Right.
So if you do something like
that, put a visual indication
on the bottom of the screen, the
approximate location, it
will probably help
a little bit.
But it would be a hack.
But it would work, probably.l
RICHARD DUNN: We will definitely
look into a way to
have some way to select people
via the filmstrip.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
OK, so moving on to
the next question.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
asked, I need a consistent
unique ordering for all
participants of a Hangout.
I thought display index would be
suited for this, however, I
periodically run into the
situation where it seems
multiple participants have the
same display index value.
Can somebody explain this?
This seems to be related to
whether a user is just present
in the Hangout or they've
started my Hangout app.
RICHARD DUNN: Interesting.
Well, taking it from the end
back, I would say multiple
people having the same display
index seems like a bug to me.
So we should probably look into
whether that happens.
And as for the first part,
like just getting the
consistent number, I think,
Will, you've had a feature
request opened for
that as well.
Like an absolute ordering
based on when they--
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, I'd be
really interested in knowing--
and either an absolute order.
You can do it a little bit by
looking at the time stamp on
when they arrived
in the Hangout.
You know, you have somebody
just call a set
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] as soon
as they walk in.
And then just declare that's
an arbitrary order.
It's not necessarily the order
they appear in the thumb
strip, but it is an arbitrary
ordering.
JD SALAZAR: If you don't care
about the ordering and getting
people jumping in the
middle [INAUDIBLE]
like Hangout ID or
something, too.
It just depends on what you're
looking for, I guess.
RICHARD DUNN: I would definitely
like to add--
just because it's super easy
for us to add, I would
definitely like to add some
sort of absolute ordering.
But in terms of the display
index, my expectation would be
that they were always
different.
So that's a surprise to hear.
JOHN BERRY: He actually updated
his post with an edit,
and said, just realized I'm
using Get Participants while
using Get Enabled Participants
guarantees that
display index is unique.
Consistent order across
all users.
And he ends with a
question mark.
So I think the question
we should raise is Get
Participants versus Get
Enabled Participants.
RICHARD DUNN: Actually,
I know what this--
I wonder if that might be
that, if they leave--
well, then they'd disappear.
GERWIN STURM: I think
that problem might
be the display index.
If I have to display index two
for someone, someone else in
the Hangout might have
the same person
display index three.
Because the ordering isn't
unique among all participants.
So that might be the problem
he's having.
JD SALAZAR: I think
that's true.
I think that you can't guarantee
that participants
will be displayed in
the same order for
everyone in the Hangout.
GERWIN STURM: So that might
be the problem.
That the display index two is
different for me than for
someone else in the Hangout.
RICHARD DUNN: Well, Jonathan,
can you forward
that message to me?
We'll definitely fix that.
WILL THOMPSON: Assuming it's
buggy, we will fix it.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Thanks for the bug report.
So moving on to the
next question.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
asks, is it possible to access
Picasa photos within a Google+
Hangout that were shared from
another Picasa web account?
So within--
or actually, someone else
like to field this one?
I will field--
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, actually
it is possible, because if
it's a public photo
you can access it.
Because you can access all
Picasa photos, so you can use
the Picasa data API to
access those photos.
You just would need the Google
ID of the person you want to
have the photos access of.
And now with the possibility
that you can actually add
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
to your Hangout, the ones you
want, you can actually request
limited photos as well, which
have been shared with you in
some cases.
JOHN BERRY: That is a super
awesome feature
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] just
rolled out.
And I know you worked
on a photo app.
So why don't you explain a
little bit about what you had
to do to do that?
Because it's not so
straightforward.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, so actually
for my photo app I'm
using the Picasa data API
to access the photo.
So I'm taking my Google IT,
and use it to access the
Picasa data API that can request
albums which I have.
And I can request the photos in
the albums, and then just
put the link to the photo
actually put into the shared
state, so the others can
have the link for
the photo to be displayed.
And this should work for my
photos or for the photos of
others as well.
So if I know the link
to a photo I can
share it in the Hangout.
JOHN BERRY: Pretty neat.
GERWIN STURM: Actually, I could
just screen share the
app if you want, if anyone's
interested.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN BERRY: And you're using
the JS client, right?
The--
GERWIN STURM: Actually for the
data API I'm just using the
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
requests to access it.
So let's see if I can
screen share this.
OK, do you see it?
So actually what I'm doing on
this side here, I'm just
loading all my Picasa albums.
The public Picasa albums.
Where the Picasa data
API and then just
can choose one album.
So this side part here, this is
only private to me in the
Hangout app.
And now I can choose
one photo.
It shares the link with all
the other people who
are using the app.
And they can see the same
display if they
are using the app.
So that's about it
what I'm doing.
And if you, actually it should
be possible if you do access
albums of other people, as long
as they are public and
you have the IT.
So in this case I'm just
refilling the API
with my Google IT.
So it accesses my albums, but in
the same way you can access
the public albums of other
people as well.
So you could actually just
say, I want to access the
public albums of Richard, and
then it would be able to
display them and share
those photos as well.
JOHN BERRY: And again, that's
using the Picasa
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API, which [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
unrelated Google+, but because
Picasa and Google+ photos are
related, he's able to do that.
Cool.
Cool integration.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, the photos
on Google+ use the Picasa
backend, so that's the
relationship between them.
The Picasa APIs allow you
to access some of them.
Cool, thank you very much
for demoing that.
That was really--
So continuing on through
the questions.
Joshua asks another question.
What is the best way
to detect when a
Hangout app gets unloaded?
So that I could do some
cleanup once it's been
unloaded, for example?
Anyone?
JD SALAZAR: Sorry.
Could you repeat the question?
JENNY MURPHY: What is the best
way to detect when a Hangout
app becomes unloaded?
For example, if you want
to do a clean up.
RICHARD DUNN: So we don't
really have--
We don't have this notion of--
I guess there's two answers
to that, right?
There is the other
people that are--
other instances of the
app can detect that.
Yeah, so other instances of the
app can detect that that
person's left the app, if they
want to do clean up there.
What we don't have is, we don't
have a way that the app
instance itself, when
it gets unloaded,
has time to do anything.
We basically just kill it off.
So it's an open question
of whether that's a
good thing to do.
I guess there are some nice
things that can be done there.
WILL THOMPSON: Well, yeah.
It's certainly sort of like
the OnApp hidden event.
JOHN BERRY: Yeah, so there's
the OnApp hidden, which I
think is the second
answer to that.
Because apps don't run
if you hide it.
So for example if you toggle an
extension, or if the app,
you switch over to the video
feed, at that point, we fire
an event that says--
I think that's exactly
what you call
the app, OnApp hidden.
So if you have animation,
you might want
to pause the animation.
Or if you want to-- if you've
queued up background data that
you need to send out to your
server, that may be a good
time to do that.
And if you want to do something
if the user leaves,
and there's other users on your
app, then you could do
the On Enable Participant
Changed, and say, hey, we have
a lost user and it's
changed the games.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
That's [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
ALAN FURTZENBURG: People have
asked me this question as
well, in regards to suggestions
that I've made
about how to trigger something
when a Hangout is
started with an app.
How it can then go communicate
with a web server.
They said, well how do
you do the opposite?
If a person leaves without
anybody showing up, how do you
clear that value?
And I said, uh, that's a
really good question.
And the best solution that I
had come up with, that I
hadn't tested yet, was to attach
something to the iframe
and detect when the
iframe was close.
So when it receives an
On Close event for--
I forget the correct
name of the event.
But I haven't tested it yet, and
I don't know for sure how
it'll work, how well it will
work, or what other problems
that are associated with that.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Thanks for the possible
solution.
Which would work
in most cases.
Someone killed the process
in the web browser.
You wouldn't get that--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILL THOMPSON: In that
case, you almost
might consider a KeepAlive.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, a KeepAlive
or a heartbeat?
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, just once
a minute, be like, oh, this
Hangout's still going with this
app, and then, nope, this
Hangout's not going anymore.
[INAUDIBLE]
JENNY MURPHY: Interesting.
JOHN BERRY: In KeepAlive 108,
which I've been experimenting
with this morning, is
Google analytics.
JENNY MURPHY: Google analytics
for KeepAlive?
JOHN BERRY: Yeah, right.
So with the new real time
infrastructure.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, the real
time [UNINTELLIGIBLE]?
RICHARD DUNN: Are you
actually working on
editing that, Johnson?
JOHN BERRY: No, I was just
playing around with Google
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] this morning,
and I've been doing some
things around trying to look
at the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API, right?
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
API, as well as the JavaScript
wrapper.
So there's some cool things that
you can experiment with
inside of the Hangout.
JENNY MURPHY: This is actually
a problem that's existed in
web applications pretty much
from the beginning.
Is you don't know when
people disappear.
So there are a lot
of solutions out
there on the web.
And any solution that's been
out there to solve this
problem for regular, traditional
web applications
will also be able to help
you figure out--
for example, if you have server
side state that you
need to clean up when the
Hangout app is closed.
WILL THOMPSON:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
Whatever it is that
you need to do.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
Cool.
Okey doke.
So moving on to the next one.
Chad asks, is there any chance
that facial tracking will be
able to support multiple
faces?
So like we have right here,
four people on camera.
WILL THOMPSON: Wow, that
would be cool.
JENNY MURPHY: It would.
[LAUGHTER]
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNY MURPHY: OK, moving
on to the next one.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Then we
have [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
games in the Hangout.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, we have no
announcements about that.
JOHN BERRY: I will say, as we're
developing two of us on
the screen, the standard use
case for Hangouts is you in
front of your laptop.
Definitely right now we're
behind a camera and it's
getting all four of us.
But most people use Hangouts
while their on their laptop.
WILL THOMPSON: This is the use
case why you need a mark when
you're doing puppets.
Like [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
or playing a game
with your head.
Mark which face you are
actually attached to.
WILL THOMPSON: It should
say "one-up."
WILL THOMPSON: P1.
JENNY MURPHY: P1.
P1, P2, P3, P4?
That would be cool.
WILL THOMPSON: I think his
next question was, gosh,
wouldn't it be cool
if there's WebGL?
And the answer is, yeah,
that'd be so cool.
That's how the 3D robot
floating head works.
It's in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
So again--
JOHN BERRY: Yeah.
He said something simpler.
He said, I want to see a face
tracker in my [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
image.
And somebody was demoing--
JD-- the--
JD SALAZAR:
J.D. SALAZAR: I don't actually
have this app.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOHN BERRY: But it was a picture
of John Malkovich, and
his mouth was moving
with your mouth.
And it was pretty striking,
as well.
It's doable with the
current API.
JENNY MURPHY: Is that one
open source anywhere?
JOHN BERRY: I have no idea.
JD was the one who was
playing with it
JENNY MURPHY: So a lot of the
hangout applications are
actually open source.
So if you track them down,
sometimes you can figure out
how people did them, too.
WILL THOMPSON: Right
click, Resource.
JENNY MURPHY: That
works, also.
Cool, so just moving up the
stream of questions.
WILL THOMPSON: But yeah, I would
actually add that WebGL
is really great in the Hangouts,
as opposed to Flash,
because it's running natively
rather than
running in a plug-in.
It's awesome.
JOHN BERRY: Gerwin has some
experience, right?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah.
A little bit.
JOHN BERRY: I think, Gerwin,
you're the first person to try
WebGL inside of Hangout.
So you get that--
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, I think it
was the first thing I tried
with a Hangout app actually.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
OK, so there's a question
unrelated to Hangouts API that
Harold asks, that
I will answer.
Harold asks, how do I use the
Google+ +1 button on a web
page, and it seems that Google
apps users can't use it.
The complaint is that
login is required in
response to the RPC call.
He's also having trouble with
the badge, which renders as a
big white box.
So this could depend
on a lot of things.
And the easiest thing is for
us is just hook up and
troubleshoot.
It could be an issue because
it's a JavaScript that's
running on your page it can
sometimes be in conflict with
other JavaScript on your page.
Or even web server
configuration, because our
buttons will fetch your page to
create the snippet, and if
they can't access it for some
reason, our page fetchers
can't access it, that will
cause problems, also.
So in other reasons, there's a
lot of things that could be
causing these issues.
So I'll look back with you after
the broadcast, and we'll
solve your problems. We'll
get back to you.
So, moving up the thread.
While I'm poking around on the
thread, does anyone in the
Hangout have any other questions
or comments they'd
like to chat about?
Announcements?
GERWIN STURM: So I actually
don't have a question--
So I actually don't have a
question, but a suggestion,
really, because you just start
with the on-air functionality
in Hangout apps.
There's actually three things
I want to see in there.
Actually, I think would be
interesting to see who's the
one hosting the Hangout
on there.
So which of the participants
is the one who broadcasts?
So that he maybe can get special
privileges inside of
the Hangout app.
Then there's the thing with
the YouTube URL, so we can
link it and I can use it
in the comment tracker.
And then also the link to
the broadcast URL on
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] which
announces the--
so those are actually
the three things.
Actually, I would be happy with
the broadcast, because
there's a lot of things you
could do with that.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: [INAUDIBLE]
the outgoing volume.
RICHARD DUNN: What's that?
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Being able to
adjust the outgoing volume
to the video stream, so you
can use volume control to
adjust actually the video,
audio levels from all the
participants as a host.
RICHARD DUNN: OK.
More good suggestions.
WILL THOMPSON: And definitely
more metadata about the
Hangout on air, is
what I'm hearing.
Has anybody ever tried to put
the Hangout on air broadcast
inside the Hangout?
What would happen?
It's like the IT Crowd.
Searching for Google inside
Google causes
the internet to close.
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN BERRY: Then they do a
screen share with the video--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WILL THOMPSON: Screen share the
broadcast inside the Hangout.
That would be awesome.
We should try that.
JENNY MURPHY: Do you want
to try it right now?
WILL THOMPSON: I don't want to
set fire to this room, so we
better not.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we're in
a new room, which is not as
equipped as previous ones.
So we don't want our work
lab to catch on fire.
But later when it's a
different computer.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah.
We'll see if we open a wormhole
in time and space.
JOHN BERRY: I don't know about
you guys, but I don't own a
fire retardant suit.
JENNY MURPHY: You don't?
JOHN BERRY: Nope.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JENNY MURPHY: They're
useful when
doing things like welding.
All the wool.
Wool clothing is very
fire resistent.
Just in case you were
wondering, everyone.
WILL THOMPSON: You don't
have asbestos gloves?
JENNY MURPHY: No, I
actually don't.
WILL THOMPSON: They gave those
to us in high school.
It was amazing.
It was like, later on,
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
But as it was.
JENNY MURPHY: Anyway,
moving on.
[INAUDIBLE]
asked a question earlier about
the Picasa photos being
accessible from the Hangout
app, actually
clarifies the question.
Actually, I mean for non-public
Picasa web photos
shared via Google+ from
a different account.
So I'm assuming this would be if
Martin would share a photo
with just me, would I
be able to access--
oh, we can access our own Picasa
web via [INAUDIBLE],
but there doesn't seem to be a
way to access the photo that
Martin shared to me,
for example.
Is there a way?
So this is starting to get to
one of the corners where using
these multiple APIs together
doesn't always work
wonderfully.
The Picasa web APIs do not
include all of the features of
the security model Google+, for
example, which is built on
the same backend, but uses the
slightly different system for
managing all the sharing
and stuff.
I am not aware of a way to
do this specific thing.
It's a great question.
I do not believe you can
do it with the current
APIs that are available.
But I think you've done
more hacking on these
APIs than I, Gerwin.
Do you have any input?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, I actually
only used public APIs without
the [UNINTELLIGIBLE], so I'm not
sure what is possible with
the Picasa data.
They're actually pretty
difficult to work with, to
actually get to know
how to use them.
So I haven't really went into
all the stuff with the Picasa.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, they're
using our older, G data style
APIs, which are different than
the APIs that, for example,
Google+ uses.
And as a result they have a
little bit more rough edges.
We learned a lot when we built
all the API infrastructure,
and as a result we like our
new APIs a lot more.
So you're in an interesting
case, where you're having to
work with both of them at
the same time, which is
challenging.
And if you can find
a way let us know.
It's cool.
And with that question,
we're actually just
about out of time.
JOHN BERRY: Well there's one
question I wanted to answer.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, there's
one question you
wanted to answer, huh?
JOHN BERRY: Somebody asked,
where you can get all those
cool stickers on your laptop?
[LAUGHTER]
JOHN BERRY: So this one right
here, this G+ sticker, you can
actually buy it from the
online Google store.
We just started shipping that.
So you can get a pack of five
for a couple of bucks US.
And I'm pretty sure it ships
internationally.
WILL THOMPSON: And we have
the old +1 button.
We have all kinds of--
JOHN BERRY: But the only one
you can buy is this guy.
Actually, my HTML5 one, which
I'm very proud of, you can get
from the HTML5 site, and a
bunch of other places.
The JS one, the logo's
at opensource.
You can print it yourself.
And the Hangouts one and
the circles one, you'll
have to bribe us.
WILL THOMPSON: You'll
JENNY MURPHY: You'll
have to do awesome.
Do extra awesome.
JOHN BERRY: I actually send out
stickers to people who do
cool things, or help me out,
or help the community.
So if you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah,
so do cool stuff.
Let us know.
WILL THOMPSON: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
like move his
laundry over or something.
He's like, here's a sticker.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: There are a
couple of questions on the
YouTube page that may be of
interest. Somebody asked, as a
regular user, is there a page
that lists the Hangout apps?
Anything like the Chrome web
store for Hangout apps.
I know that we all needed
to register with
the Chrome web store.
What are the plans for a web
store for Hangout apps?
RICHARD DUNN: Well
Hangoutapps.com has been doing
a pretty good job of listing
all of them.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, that's
a community project that's
pretty cool.
JOHN BERRY: The short answer for
that is, there are plans,
and we're still developing
them.
A lot of that is based
on feedback.
The main way that people
discover is through the viral
nature of apps.
If somebody's doing a Hangout
with an app and
you discover it.
And then, we're recommending
people make plus pages to
drive traffic to their
Hangout app.
Either a Hangout app per plus
page, or if you have a brand
that you've created around
your apps, or just
my apps plus page.
And Google's trying to strive
to build platforms for
developers.
So a way to distribute and
monetize is definitely on our
radar, and we're working
towards that.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: You had
somebody who agrees with the
special privileges of the
Hangout creator to boot and
mute a user who's causing
a problem.
And I know that comes up
frequently in the Hangout
discussions.
And a request. Please implement
messaging from G+
app to the web browser while a
friend is within your circle.
What are the plans for
interaction between the app
and the chat window?
RICHARD DUNN: Well, obviously
that's a big request. I think
there's some sensitivity
around chat.
I don't know quite if that's
pushing stuff into the chat
window or pulling it out.
Pulling it out is obviously--
[LAUGHTER]
RICHARD DUNN: Yeah I mean, we're
looking at those issues
and we're trying to solve
some of them.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we're
working through the chat
issue, but we're just very
cautious about interacting
with the chat too much because
we don't want it to either
become too noisy.
And we also don't want to
compromise the privacy of
anyone in the chat.
So we're taking a cautious
approach to
this particular feature.
But there's some cool potential
there, so we'll see.
ALAN FURTZENBURG: And finally
from the YouTube chats,
several people thanking
for the answer.
And finally, this is
an awesome Hangout.
[LAUGHTER]
JENNY MURPHY: And it's awesome
because all of
you guys joined us.
WILL THOMPSON: From
Google engineers
to all of our community.
It's really been great.
JENNY MURPHY: And the overlap
of our community and Google
engineering.
So thanks very much to
everyone for joining.
This has been a really great
session in our new location,
which will hopefully have
a dinosaur next time.
WILL THOMPSON: Yeah, we need to
get a whiteboard so we can
plan a dinosaur.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, we'll
figure it out.
WILL THOMPSON: Somebody will
provide a dinosaur.
JENNY MURPHY: But in regards to
this video, there will be
an edited version published to
the Google+ developers page.
It'll include the show
notes, like we
have for every session.
And it'll be up later
today or tomorrow.
In the meantime--
JOHN BERRY: And also the YouTube
Google Developers
[INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: It'll
also be added to
YouTube.com/GoogleDevelopers way
at the bottom of the page
under the Google+ platform
office hours.
It'll also be visible there.
And the show notes will
be there too.
Well, until next
session, thanks
everyone for joining us.
See
you later ALL: Bye.